hello everyone
thank you for joining today's meeting i
would like to welcome you all today's
webinar on genomics in the virtual
lab genomics in the virtual lab is an
online program and a unique opportunity
for high school students
and beginners this program is led by
professor sona vasudevan from georgetown
university medical center washington d.c
bioclues organization india and nishta
sri lanka
and fine biotech usa so let me start
with introduction about
us we are a u.s based bioinformatics
company who is working with multiple
academics and commercial collaborators
to develop
easy to use analytical tools and our
mission
is to make bioinformatics more
accessible
we are doing this by providing training
and tools that help students and
researchers make discoveries
using next-generation sequencing data
science and other bioinformatics
technologies
and tools omixlogic research-based
training programs are a result of close
collaboration between pine biotech
and numerous academic institutions that
have participated in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design as
a result the omixlogic programs have
been thoroughly tested around the world
and are known
to lead to excellent outcomes for
students
with minimal bioinformatics background
including biology
and biomedical study majors as well as
faculty interested in bioinformatics
data science
and biomedical research
my name is sunalika ray and i am the
omixlogic community manager responsible
for daily interactions with thousands of
users that are a part of a
bioinformatics community
managed by pine biotech i'm honored to
have been working
with a team that collectively has
amazing experience in this area
including the other school other
co-founders of the company dr
alfred trauber who is working
who comes from a medical background with
expertise in oncology immunology and
biochemistry of information
and one of these projects is the
establishment of the topper
research center which has been at the
core of what we do
dr leonid brodsky is the director of the
toba bioinformatics research center
and he is an expert in bioinformatics
and biostatistics
he has numerous publications on
bioinformatics and over the course of
his career he has developed multiple
novel algorithmic approaches to
biomedical data analysis
these have been widely used in basic and
translational research in biotechnology
pharmaceutical r d
agriculture and basic research our
platform is a result of hard work by
some of the people mentioned here on the
right
julia paner who was an expert by
bioinformatician
and has helped prepare many of the
materials that we would use
avitovsky is a computer scientist and
leads the development of the tbio info
platform that we would be using as a
part of the
course and i will also be introducing
our team members in india
in the next few slides so dr harpreet
has an expertise in the application of
statistical machine learning techniques
on biomedical data
and the development of prediction tools
and databases
and she looks after the curriculum
development bioinformatics and data
science course development
dr mohit mazumdar he's an expert by
information
with multiple publications in
peer-reviewed journals and
collaborations
in industrial academia over the past
several years he has been developing
collaborations with universities
as a mentor and project lead for omix
logic training and research fellowship
now coming back to the program genomics
in the virtual lab is a special
opportunity to learn about
genomics and big data analysis from a
world-renowned scientist and a team of
bioinformaticians
working on cutting-edge big data
challenges in biomedical research
professor sona vasudevan professor of
biochemistry
and molecular biology at the georgetown
university medical center
will present disease associated projects
that program participants can learn from
to see how genomics is used at the
intersection of data science
and biomedicine in this online program
participants will learn about the
analysis of high throughput genomics
data
and apply complex and computationally
intensive data processing steps
to large-scale public domain data
the program would include certification
for participation
as well as excellence and the
certificate of excellence would be
provided to students who would exceed
the progress expectations
and complete the online courses and
propose a novel bioinformatics project
now i would like to pass it on to ceo
pine biotech ilya brodsky over to you
india
thank you very much let me show my
screen
welcome everyone to today's session i'm
excited to see so many of you
joining and hopefully what we will be
able to provide you with
is a brief view of the topics that we'll
be covering
as well as introduce you to the main
program
coordinator dr sono vasudevan and some
of the other participants and partners
that we have
joining this program to talk about their
need for
research in using bioinformatics and
using data science
so my name is elia brodsky as sonalik
already mentioned i'm one of the
co-founders of pine biotech so i wanted
to kind of briefly
introduce what we do why are we
organizing this program
and where can you envision yourself
applying bioinformatics after completing
a program like this
so probably many of you have heard about
the uh genomic revolution right and so
the genomic revolution
started uh in the 20th century we're now
in the 21st century so it really started
in the past uh
century but it didn't happen so long ago
and
over the past 50 or 60 years
there has been a tremendous growth in
the
type of sequencing data interest
in the human genome and other type of
genomic data
and really a revolution going on
using such genomic data in many
different aspects
of biotechnology agriculture and
biomedicine
and essentially what genomics often
boils down to is analysis of the genomic
code to identify
variation and that variation could lead
to
these changes in the phenotype so
essentially
the change in the genomic sequence could
lead to a change in the way that cells
tissues and organisms look and function
and those could be
diseases or they could be natural
variation
like different color of skin different
length of your eyelashes
or maybe even different height and
things like that so
what we think of typically when we
consider genomics is this idea of
finding bugs in the code right so those
of you that are coming from an
engineering background maybe familiar
with
coding and data science having code work
perfectly is almost impossible
as you're developing that code and so
oftentimes finding that bug can really
help you understand
what is going wrong with a function or
some kind of an algorithm that you're
trying to run
now where is genomics applied especially
in the area of biomedicine genomics is
extremely important for understanding
drug metabolism
so we understand how different proteins
are able to process
different types of chemicals and
typically drugs are those chemicals that
we want to make sure that they're
metabolized
properly you can also think of genomics
and application to cancer so
somatic mutations and tumor development
inherited mutations like in sickle cell
anemia
where the adaptation to different
diseases has led to these phenotypic
changes that are now
causing some kind of a susceptibility to
disease
rare genetic diseases that
could be linked to repetitive elements
in our dna
and also drug resistance and obviously
now living in this pandemic
we know about genomics so much more
because it's been in the news it's been
in the
media everybody knows about the
mutations the variance of concern
everybody has been hearing about this
and so it's an extremely
important domain for research but also
an application
to different areas in biomedicine in
fact today
genomics is truly in the clinic and so
you can see here an
example of a report that is being
produced to kind of establish risk for
developing certain types of
conditions and this is a routinely used
method
in the medical field today at least in
some of the western countries and so i
think what's very important is that
genomics is moving away from just being
purely in research
and being actively used in clinical uh
in the clinical setting and we see this
um
as an as a very important development
primarily because the cost of sequencing
is much lower availability of reference
data
is much greater and so there is already
a clear
and established relationship between
specific changes
in the dna code and specific diseases
and conditions that could be clinically
categorized
but it hasn't always been like that and
even today there's an active
research also on the impact of specific
mutations
because if you consider how these
mutations occur
and how do they actually lead to
diseases
it's a complicated coordinated kind of
an effect of multiple multiple factors
so here you can see
the significance of dna variation in
cancer where
acquired mutations germline mutations
mutations in different types of genes
and
in dna repair genes all of those come
together to form
a certain level of risk after which
there could be an event that could
trigger some of those
important changes in critical genes and
ultimately
lead to what we know as unregulated
tumor growth and development
and so these types of changes
are really important for us to
understand from the basics
of genomics and the basics of what this
data
could show us about these diseases
because
detecting those changes early on and
also
knowing the context of specific
mutations can really help
us understand how to treat diseases that
previously
were essentially untreatable now more
than just
individual mutations there are many
different types
of mutations so there are many different
types of variations
like multiple nucleotide changes at the
same time
changes that accumulate in a specific
region
maybe translocation so certain regions
even
moving to another position or maybe copy
number variation right so
many different types of changes in the
dna and importantly
it's not just the human dna but also the
dna
of many different other bacteria
viruses and parasites that are important
for
the disease progression and treatment
and so i hope that in this program we'll
have an opportunity to see
how genomic data could be used to
understand many of these
conditions and how can we study genomic
data so that we understand
the important factors that are
that are essentially critical for
understanding of disease
treating disease tracking epidemics like
the epidemic that we're seeing now
or other potential epidemics that we
might see
in the future but i think the critical
part of this program
is that it will provide you with an
insight
about next generation sequencing data
how that data is generated
what does this data really represent in
terms of the technical
part of genomic data sequencing
and then we'll allow you to evaluate
some of this genomic data
using these practical data sets that we
will take
to understand where do we see just
simple variation
where can we track mutation how do we
then
categorize mutations and understand
what do these mutations really mean for
the phenotype
and so we will make sure that in this
program after you
complete the training you will be able
to understand the different terminology
of what is a nucleotide how
can we categorize different changes of
nucleotides
how do we then annotate those
nucleotides and how can we
essentially find this association with a
phenotype
including some examples of what these
phenotypes
might mean now all of this together
is really the domain of bioinformatics
because bioinformatics
combines informatics the information
technologies that allow us to
retrieve store annotate and efficiently
use
different types of information
statistics
or using statistical methods to be able
to analyze such data
and the domain where we apply this in
the
domain of life sciences or biology so
that includes biological research
biotechnology agriculture genetics and
biomedicine and essentially
because of this growth of
data the availability of data and the
need to
use this data in a meaningful way we
have developed this omics logic training
that includes
different types of data repositories
mentorship and training and this program
is one example of such training that we
offer
to be able to equip the next generation
of life science researchers clinicians
and industry professionals that will
essentially transform the way
medicine is being done the way that new
drugs are being brought to market
and the way that we can innovate early
discoveries
that will inform different types of
applications in the future
so the reason why we call this omics
logic is because
the data that we are describing here
genomic data
is just one of the omics data types that
is becoming more and more
useful and prominent in this field
and so omixlogic combines different
user-friendly tools including different
methods of statistical analysis and
machine learning
it includes the logic behind
experimental design
so that we can understand the technical
variation in the data
it gives you access to big data mining
tools that you can easily use to study
this data
and it provides also examples of how
this data could be efficiently analyzed
to spot significant changes in the
context of real world studies
and so this omics logic
program is one program that is going to
be
available on june 21st and it provides
you with a complete
roadmap to get started and learning
about bioinformatics and about genomics
in general so
in this program you'll be able to find
data sets explore them and visualize
them
understand research methods and get
insight and
understanding potentially leading you to
an independent practice project
that you can develop in a short period
of time so
to kind of give you a little bit more
detail about omixlogic and
beyond this program that we're
discussing today what it offers
i would just briefly ask all of you to
go to our
omixlogic portal which is
[Music]
learn.omicslogic.com
and so i am sorry posted in the
wrong chat here um okay thank you very
much
so um to kind of give you a sense of how
this program will work
and how all of this content is going to
be organized
let me briefly show you um how you can
get started today
so if you go if you could go with me to
our portal and please let me know
in the chat once you are there
okay you can put there or yes or
something
you will find that there's a
button to log in and you can create a
free account
on here or log in with your social media
so i want to show you briefly how this
is going to work
okay thank you brazili manali
all right thank you sonanika so please
let me know once you're in and you've
registered
punita
okay anyone else if you already have an
account
once you log in and you're in
you can go right here to programs
and on the program page you will find
genomics in the virtual lab and so this
program right here
is going to provide you with all of the
information about today's session
and what you will learn in this program
and
after a few minutes we will hear a
little bit more
about what are the different topics and
how this is going to be
delivered so here you can see
an overview of the schedule
and some of the important tools that you
will get access to so let me
briefly tell you what are some of these
program resources
that you will be getting access to as a
part of this program
so for different parts of the program we
will
leverage onyx logic resources that are
designed
to help you learn about genomics and
this includes a synchronous coursework
with theoretical material quizzes
and practical assignments our
cloud-based analytical server
where you can analyze large genomic data
and visualize results
the onyx logic code playground when you
where you can practice coding in r
and python as well as a repository of
project examples
that will guide you from data the logic
of the analysis
to the practical exercises that you can
replicate
the analysis that was described in the
publication
so first of all we will have an
asynchronous course that you can join
and
a lot of this you can actually start
looking at for free
which is an introduction to genomics if
you're absolutely new to genomics this
is the place to start
you can go to this course to understand
the applications of genomics some of the
basic terminology
maybe some refreshment of your molecular
biology so you understand what is dna
how is it translated into proteins and
things like that
and then you will also learn about how
genomic data is generated
and how you can analyze this data to
extract meaningful information from it
so to get started you actually don't
need
to know a lot of coding all you will
need to know is the logic behind
what you are trying to do so what is the
data described
and how you might potentially analyze
this data
and so that is going to be done using
the t bioinfo server which is a big data
analysis platform
that provides you with easy to use
graphical user interface
where you just push buttons and get some
kind of a result
immediately and so on this platform you
will see
these maps logical maps of complex
analytical pipelines that will allow you
to process data
from raw format to a structured format
and once that analysis is done you will
get introduced to
important functions and tools using r
and python that will provide you with a
clear
insight about how coding is a critical
component of bioinformatics
and what you can do using these existing
packages to quickly get results
of sequence analysis and
annotation so again we
hope that this can get you started and
even before this program is launched
you can start learning about the
fundamentals of genomics of
code and analysis and the applications
of bioinformatics
about this kind of biomedical
these kinds of biomedical applications
so now
to talk a little bit more about genomics
in the virtual lab which is
a an intensive program that is intended
to provide
some of the basic material and the
grounding in genomics
as well as see some of the potential
applications of genomics to biomedical
challenges
i want to describe how these programs
are going to leverage some of these
asynchronous resources that i briefly
spoke about
and give you an opportunity to immerse
yourself
into this genomic data analysis
experience
that will combine interactive sessions
on zoom like we're having today
self-guided study materials that you
will have access to
and some of these practical assignments
that will include in-class assignments
but also
assignments that you can do yourself and
then present your results
to your peers and to the mentor of the
program
so the program as was already mentioned
is going to be run primarily by dr sona
vasudevan she has an extensive
background with research but also
she loves teaching and to talk a little
bit more about herself
her background and how this program is
going to
be done i want to pass it on to dr sona
vasudevan
from georgetown university
you probably have to make sona a co-host
for her to share
yes i'm not getting the option helia can
you please check
okay there we go thank you so much
hey there we are finally thank you and
i'm sorry
uh there was some technical glitch and
that kind of leads me to uh what uh
the course is all about uh thank you
ilya and i want to thank
pine biotechnology mohit sunalika
and others for giving me the opportunity
to actually run this course
and i'm very very excited so good
morning good afternoon good evening to
all of you
i'm sure you're all from different parts
of the world here
and it's an honor to have all of you and
thank you for taking the time
to be here today to listen about what
the course is all about
uh ilya has already done most of the
work for me
in terms of laying the foundation of why
bioinformatics
and informatics and data science is
extremely
important today uh it almost seems like
you wake up and i'm sure all of you
sleep with their phones wake up with
their phones um look up things online so
look up things on your phone and
everything else right so technology has
moved
pretty fast in the last 10 years or so
i got into bioinformatics about 15 years
ago or even more little more than that
and i have actually witnessed every day
how things have changed and where we are
today
and it seems like in the last 15 years
we have huge amount of data that is
accumulated
we have patient data we have sequencing
data from animals we have
so much of data so one thing i'm sure
all of you will agree with me today
is that we are drowning in data
from all different uh walks of life
right so
bioinformatics is about
trying to figure out how to use this
data meaningfully
and right now it's as illya also
explained very clearly that
the field of medicine and looking at
diseases
has completely changed so we all need
data science
to be able to understand diseases from
sequences
and so that's what i'm doing for a
living i
am a professor at georgetown university
in the department of biochemistry as
sonalika introduced me earlier um i
also direct a master's program in
the field called systems medicine i'm
not sure how many of you have actually
learned
heard about that it's a very new field
and i
call this a new language and i feel that
this language encompasses bioinformatics
and this is a language that all of us
need to learn sooner or later to be able
to converse and understand diseases
better
so the summary of that program
or what systems medicine means is one
size doesn't fit all
so two people you and me may have the
same cold and cough
and everything but the same medication
may not work in you
as well as it works in me and we are
still living in the panda beach
hopefully we'll get out of this soon
um but we all have learned one thing
that each person is different each
person reacts to this virus differently
because we're all
underlying makeup of our genome is very
very different
so how does that relate to the course
genomics in which labs so
as elias said right there are mutations
and there are variations in your genome
so the way i look at things is if there
is a mutation in your gene
it gets personal so any change in your
gene
is going to affect the genome in some
way
and it manifests itself in diseases i'm
sure you all know that
majority of the diseases hormonogenic
diseases
where a single mutation affects a
particular gene
in the human genome that leads to
diseases
there is only one mutation so you may
ask a genome is like
six feet we have billions of base pairs
and how one single mutation
is affecting the gene and we end up
getting diseases
right so that is what this course is all
about how
important genes are to the functioning
of the body
and how single mutations in a gene
lexicals cell anemia or huntington's
disease or
any of those diseases how that one
single mutation
is altering the gene and manifests
itself
in diseases so the genomics in which lab
you all probably will see the syllabus
at some point in time
or if you have not already seen that it
is
um two weeks a course
and it starts with uh introduction to
what bioinformatics is
and what big data is and then you'll you
will learn a lot of different resources
that actually are reliable resources
that gives you all the information that
you need to go and understand
a protein sequence which chromosome does
this protein
belong to or gene belongs to does it
have a three-dimensional structure
and how do you relate sequence to
functions which becomes very very
important
how are drugs designed how do we get
drugs and i'm sure in the score with
time you all know rem deceiver came
about very quickly
and made it to the clinic so how did
that happen
so all of those things will be covered
so we have both lecture based
and also we have hands-on that goes with
it
you will learn to learn a lot of
different resources you will learn a lot
of different tools
that you can apply to any disease that
you're interested in working
and so then after the lecture and the
hands-on sessions and we'll also have
a renowned a person in the field of
bioinformatics that we have we will
invite who will actually give you
uh the importance of bioinformatics from
nih or georgetown university or george
washington university
and who is going to tell you the
importance of bioinformatics
so from a practical aspects by the end
of the course
you're all going to know where
bioinformatics started and why we cannot
live without bioinformatics in this age
and what is the relevance of
bioinformatics in medicine
and how do you understand diseases and
in fact what
causes those diseases is something that
you will actually learn
it's a very intense program but
hopefully
we'll make it fun i like fun i'm not a
serious lecturer so it'll be fun we'll
have games we will do lots of things
uh we will go to your pace and uh
finally you will be amazed at
the project that you're going to come up
with um and so i'm hoping that
it will be very fruitful and you will
learn a lot
and find biotech as uh elias showed or
mixed logic is an outstanding platform
and
in my opinion is one of the best
platforms that we have
that encompasses so many different
aspects
so you're going to become budding
experts
in bioinformatics and from practical
aspects
it's going to pay you a lot of money in
terms of jobs so job opportunities are
huge
for bioinformatics right now and most of
my students who just graduated from my
program
already have jobs so from a practical
aspects this is a skill set that's going
to be very very valuable
to whatever you want to pursue in your
lives
so with that i will transfer it back to
ilia
and unless if i if you have any
questions or
uh if elia you want me to talk about
something else
or cover or any other aspects that you
think
that uh you want me to talk about
well no first of all thank you for this
overview
i do want to ask if there are any
questions
uh from the participants today
if you have any questions for dr
vasudevan
you can post them in the chat and she
will have time to answer those
in just a few minutes uh also so narika
i wanted to ask that you
um share the link to the forum
for those that might be
joining us from places that we want to
discover
[Music]
okay thank you so um as you're thinking
about your questions
this is a form that will help you
understand better those of you that have
joined today
we are asking that you um fill this out
if you would like to receive future
information
about the program start the first
session of this program is going to be
open
also to everyone so you're welcome to
invite your friends
and contacts to join the first session
which will be
discussed the whole schedule is going to
be discussed at the end of today's
session
and again if you do have any questions
feel free to post them in the chat and
we will have a time for
q a in just a few minutes now i would
like to pass it on
so monica maybe you could introduce the
next speaker
thank you so much ilya now i would like
to
invite dr subuna
from bioclues dr suvanakar worries
presently assistant professor in lovely
professional university india
and also he's the secretary of bioclues
organization
india he has been earlier post doctoral
fellow in icmr
and also changnam national university
south korea
he has done his phd in cancer genetics
and is an expert in the same field
over to you dr sukunakar
yeah thank you so much uh i hope i'm
audible to you all
yes sir you are audible
share the screen
opener
yeah please excuse me for a couple of
minutes
up or no
yeah yeah one second aparna uh yeah we
need to make her
a co-host so just one moment okay there
we go
you i think it should be working for you
now
yeah uh thank you yeah
it's it's pleasure to be part of uh
this evening uh thank you ilya
thank you sonawasadevan
all the participants i i take this
opportunity to just brief
about uh the bioclass organization where
i take a position of his secretary
uh basically bioclues has started in the
year 2005
uh with an idea of bioinformatics club
offered by experimental scientists and
the and
biographers has got a mission under
mentoring
outreach research through awareness and
entrepreneurship
uh so further uh when you talk about
bioclues it spread
across different countries more than
40-50 countries
which we are currently working on uh
so talking from india australia us
and even we have started uh
other other places across the globe and
the
milestones uh we talked about the way
back in 2005
where the virtual organization was
founded uh
co-founded by dr pashan surabarzala and
pradesh
uh vardaraj 2016 first virtual projects
conference
took off in 2007 first publication and
several conferences been organized
and it's been 16 years now
where we're under we have covered under
various
various uh points mentioned over here
and in the 2009 uh i'll just try to give
some glimpses
uh where 209 we started women in biology
forums started
with fulfilled society and and then we
become the
isf affliate introduce the bird awards
which are specifically given to the
people who are
as good expertise in the field of
bioinformatics
so uh to encourage uh in the indian
in the indian science scientific
fraternity and also
uh recognize people abroad and to the
interval
we have included ikp knowledge park at
genome valley india
structural open access general peer
review general general of international
uh journal of computational biology and
uh
first ever toll-free mentoring in
bioinformatics
in 2013 bio close overseas phd program
a joint program with albuquerque
university denmark
and 2004 into the 19 uh uh
publication we basically follow uh
publication co-op ethics like
life memberships and travel grants in
2009 we joined forces with
pine bio towards education programs
and then it started in the year 2020 we
started with bioinformatics for schools
and then we also started international
chapters
and regarding sustenance we use
inverted paid memberships corporate
memberships virtual onset
conferences project resources and we do
grants and funding yeah please next
slide
and uh to give a uh a brief introduction
like founded by dr
prashan surabarzullah and pritish raj as
soon
as i told and the present president is
the director of csr niece
and the immediate past president dr
jerome valadi
and the hound representative gps rago
and
several other vice presidents and it is
being registered as
not not for profit organization and
adheres
create to commonly sense and there are
four revenues as i mentioned
um mentoring outreach research
enterpriseship
and approximately we have around four
thousand
uh 500 plus members right now
and across 40 countries it's been spread
and uh currently we do
marshall projects and more than 250 more
250 scientists are involved
in various projects and a lot of
collaborations that
come across different uh 10 universities
and organizations across eight countries
and around 40 publications and over 100
conferences
have been presentations have been given
and we published in impact financial
between
1.15 to 11.836
and we do conduct a five
conducted five virtual conferences and
several international meetings organized
and only official direct affiliate of
international society of computational
biology and
asian specific violent bioinformatics
network in india
yeah uh i think up now you can
you can you can go ahead from this slide
yeah thank you
thank you so much sir so now i would
want to dr aparna banerjee dr aparna
banerjee
is assistant professor in catholic
university of
malaysia and also the present joint
secretary in bioclues organization
india she has done a phd from the
university of badwan india and her area
of expertise is an applied micro
biology of extreme environments
comparative genomics
and bioinformatics over to yuma thank
you so much
thank you sunadika uh thank you alia uh
thank you dr sona basudevan and dr
suguna karuvuri
um so i will take the next lead to talk
about bioclues
um bioclues have uh to system biology
have done a lot of system biology
workshops in virtual mode occasionally
too
so there have been three week
bioinformatics workshops scattering the
needs of scientists and the wetland
professionals a more than 1500 people
benefited
of or organization that we have made of
nearly 49 such events
eminent faculties from india and abroad
joined over there
several workshop has been organized in
columbus sri lanka
and all over the india we have rigorous
teaching program project in
collaboration with several organizations
like national university of singapore
florida university united states and in
italy
we also do certificate and honorarium at
the end of the workshops
so like i cannot move the
map maybe you can uh reshare your screen
that would work i think
okay stop sharing and vibration okay
thank you
yes so ah as a resource by close
organization of competent core team
we have prolific workshops and several
events we have blade server
we go through mentor mentee relationship
as we as dr buri also mentioned earlier
and we have several bio close interest
groups
so some notable projects of bio clues
has been cancer institute
chennai accessing the human smoker
population prone to lung cancer
a checkerboard analysis using ngs data
it has been also with ludhiana
university a bacteriophage genome
brosella fudge uh annotation and there
has been also the hyper project
prediction of hypothetical protein
function in humans
about the ingest expertise the studied
organism has been human cow east
bacteria
through the platform of illumina rashi
parent and multiplexed
the services that we offered are
mentoring graduate students in biology
and bioinformatics
annotate and curate ngs data sets
transcriptomic and genomic analysis of
ngs data that includes gene expression
analysis
variant analysis with or without
reference genome
genome diversity and coverage
distribution pathway analysis and
protein interactions
functional mapping with gene ontology
and pipeline developments
so talking about the gene uh our team uh
prashant surabjala and prishi pritis
bharath
they have co-founded the organization 16
years back
now the code uh is formed with president
nadhari sastry
the secretary suganakar bhuri with me
being the joint secretary
the finance chair harpreet singh and
santoshi dupatla
with the woman in biology chair with
successing and renuka surabu jalla
the student chapters are done by arvind
pritchard and raksmi
sukumaran the internship chairs are va
sundarajan and anil kumar
the outreach chair are by jairaman
valadi and mohan kumar megha
the research chairs are by pv kabhi
kishon and hima komari
with the mentoring chairs finally with
biswan adam dupatla and prashan surav
jalla
many of them actually today has joined
with us prashanth ah
dr sundarajan and they have all been the
driving force to bio clues
here are the mentioned honorary advisors
of bioclues 2 with the
founding board or executive members so
the latest conference that have been
successfully organized was in biggs 2020
uh with the being the affiliates of iscb
and apb bayonet
so there are some glimpses of index 2020
workshops that we organized
three workshops and then some glimpses
of inbix 2020 here
and finally we have also started in 2020
by informatics for school children
program and two batches have already
graduated
uh the third batch will start soon also
uh
so we focus on hands-on and home-based
learning
and we emphasis on strong stream and
curriculum product development
with a total of 12 entrancing classes
um so here
we thank you all for giving an
opportunity to talk about bio clues
and we will be um happily sharing our
expertise
in this um genomics for virtual lab
program
thank you sonalika and thank you thank
you very much
and uh i wanna just uh now pause and
i see that there are several different
questions
um maybe we could address those
questions now
so first of all uh there's a question
and uh dr vasudevan if you could please
answer these questions
so here at iqbal is asking for a basic
science person
what should be the first step to land in
the vast ocean of bioinformatics
um uh actually here that's uh that's
actually an outstanding question
because you know what i had to swim in
the ocean i don't know swimming
so now uh having gone through a long
process i can tell you the
uh the first thing is to actually um
take this course
because that gives you a foundation of
bioinformatics and
if not this course uh because it may
seem like i'm advertising for my own
course but
but fine biotechnology actually has lots
of introductory courses in genomics one
genomics too
i think those will be a good start um
for uh someone from basic sciences and i
am actually trained
as a basic scientist myself uh in fact
i'm trained as a physicist
and then moved to biology and um and i'm
from your same background as basic
sciences and i think um
when i was trying to get into the field
there were not that many courses or any
of these things so it was a hard way so
long story short it's a long answer for
a short question
i think any of the introductory courses
that's on pine biotech will be a good
start
and of course we'll be very happy to
guide you further
if you need more information
and then the second question is for a
biochemist how can we relate
pharmacogenomics with bioinformatics
actually
um that is actually a very uh relevant
question to the times we are living in
with respect to pharmacogenomics right
so pharmacogenomics
is the other term for personalized
medicine precision medicine or systems
medicine
um and so uh how can we relate so
for pharmacogenomics in my opinion and
i'm sure ilya can add to that
is um you need foundations of structural
biology
because at the end of the day you want
to learn how to design drugs
and then once you know how to design
drugs we can actually
use all the approved drugs that we have
today
to do some repurposing and so in my
opinion
it is uh and biochemistry is actually
fundamental and
prerequisite to most of the biological
processes
because you know once you have a gene
you know how biochemically it is
actually working in the cell
added to that if you add the omics part
to it i think that will be
very very important um i'm not sure if
you want to add something to it
i just wanted to ask you i i think you
were your background
is in structural biology right that's
right that's right so
um just to give my path to where i am
today i actually started as a physicist
and then by accident uh and i'm trained
as an x-ray crystallographer
so i did a phd in extra crystallography
uh and then my postdoctoral training was
actually in
wet lab molecular biology that was my
first introduction to biology
um and then so now i'm able to then i
entered bioinformatics and now i'm able
to look back and combine structural
biology because that is helping me with
respect to uh
understanding pharmacogenomics and how
one drug that
works and one does doesn't work it's all
at the end of the day
we look at biology in three dimensions
um
and so i think that's useful um and and
also maybe
we can mention that uh you know as a
biochemist
uh you know not only can you relate
pharmacogenomics
and bioinformatics you can actually
participate because i think a lot of
people that don't have that biochemistry
background
they don't appreciate as much the
interaction between the structures
uh you know they might be only looking
at the sequence level but in this
program i think
uh dr vasudevan will mention the
importance of keeping those two things
in mind
that's right that's right so it will be
a um a natural transition from
first principles biochemistry uh amino
acids and how they fold together and
how the structures made and how does
structure define the function
so thanks ilya for that note um
so let's see um
[Music]
there is a question what's the
importance of linux platforms
in bioinformatics and do i need to learn
unix for further studies in
bioinformatics
from sullivan um
so um i think as ilya said in his
introductory i think there was a very
nice slide where
i like the slide how you define
bioinformatics so bioinformatics
actually has different wings so you are
a hardcore biologist or you are a
software engineer or
you are a biostatistician so they all
come together
because bioinformatics is a very
interdisciplinary field so it depends on
which
which wing you want to pick out so
i am a hardcore researcher so i have
programmers who do the programming part
for me
and i don't do programming personally
myself
so it is an interdisciplinary field so i
either
whichever wing you want to choose
whether you want to choose research wing
which way you use other people to do the
programming or you can be that software
engineer
to actually um you know use so which
means linux platform is actually very
very important
uh in terms of most of the tools right
now
um but unix um ailia do you want to um
yeah i would just briefly add to that
that you know there's many
there are many limitations to user
interfaces um a simple example
if you want to open a large table you
can only open a table that big
and so because these user interfaces
want to load everything into the ram the
more efficient way to do that
is to use linux that has access directly
to files
without necessarily loading all the
files so you can extract information out
of a file
without opening the whole thing as we
move into the field of big data analysis
that's critical because
every file is gigabytes and gigabytes
and so you just
can't operate that without huge
resources so it's a more efficient way
of doing things
the other part of it is that many tools
are designed around linux
and so simple uh settings of those tools
how to run those script
scripts how to combine scripts into
pipelines
all of that typically is done on linux
but
as sona mentioned there are many
variations of bioinformaticians
and so there are people that design the
algorithms use the algorithms
interpret the algorithms outputs but
even generate the data for those
algorithms to use
all of those people i think need to use
bioinformatics at a certain level
and so for this program we're going to
be focused on
kind of user-friendly bioinformatics
things that you can do
on windows on mac systems you don't
necessarily need to know linux to
get all the tools that we're going to be
using here
but what you will be able to do is think
critically
about the data and the application of
these
tools to potentially research or
biomedical uh
challenges so there's a
there's a question about um from manali
um so you've graduated from
bioinformatics
um and you want to do a master's in
biome and eventually you want to do a
phd in bioinformatics which is fantastic
we really need more
trained people to help us all here uh
but my
personal advice to you i'm sure other
people would
can actually add um to this my personal
journey has been that
um trained as a structural biologist i
actually did
biology in the lab and so i find
that i'm able to operate appreciate more
of the biology side of things because
i've been in a lab
if i had completely done only sequence
analysis
just using a computer i don't think i'll
be able to appreciate the biology of it
as much as i am now able to understand
it better this is my personal view
that my advice to you would be to pick a
phd where you actually do lab work
so that you can actually come up with
predictions using bioinformatics but
actually
uh you know authenticate that prediction
and validate the predictions in an
experimental setting that makes you a
full person to understand different
things that would be my advice
but of course there are other experts in
this uh call so
um if someone else wants to add to it um
please do and so could i just ask i
think that a lot of people are
interested in joining a master's degree
program so i know that you're a
director of a master's program could you
tell
a little bit about the program itself
and what kinds of
qualities do you look for in students
that are applying yeah thank you so much
ilya for giving me the opportunity to
talk about the program so
um georgetown has the master's program
uh maybe i can actually open up
the website um and i'm not sure if i can
share so um so this is
the master's program and it's a 10-month
program
um it is from start to finish and
it actually trains you to
um all different aspects of
bioinformatics
so it is like a layered approach so you
what background you can come from any
background that is computer computer
science or
a biology or bioinformatics or
any discipline you can enter the program
and what the program when you leave the
program you're going to have a full
flavor from start to finish different
layers of
informatics you'll learn about genomics
you learn about proteomics you learn
about microbiome
um and you will learn about different
aspects of how
clinicians are using bioinformatics um
and then you will also learn how to
critically read scientific literature
and how do you translate
all of this information from all of this
data in a clinical setting
uh from bench to bedsides if i may say
that and then we'll have clinical
metabolomics
and so this is a layered approach and
also
the most important part of this program
is you also get to do research
uh in fact this program because that's
how i got to
interact with pine biotech and they play
a significant role
as well in in helping with different
courses and as well as
you know different aspects of the
program as well um
in fact there's one course that's
machine learning that elia
actually um ran and we i want to
uh you know bring that backwards back um
and so so this is different
aspects uh layered and you learn about
statistics whenever you talk about data
whenever you talk about big data
you don't know whether it's
statistically significant
and we are talking about one mutation or
one variant
that we are seeing is that variance
statistically significant right so now
we are talking about lots of covert
variance
how many people have been sequenced how
many people actually have that variant
is it even significant
right so statistics is a big part of it
um
so this is a program uh that you can
you're all welcome to apply the deadline
is actually july 1st
um i'm not sure how many of you are
ready to apply but i know most of you
are probably in high school still but
this is a program
to consider or
you know spread the word around we still
have a couple of spots left for this
coming fall it starts in september
so i posted the link to the site in the
chat
anyone that is interested and i do want
to mention that
even if you scroll through you can see
genomics in the lab and so this
experience is kind of like a view into
what this program is going to be all
about and obviously you'll have access
to uh dr vasudevan here and you can ask
her questions about any of the
topics that you might want to learn in
preparation for this program
yeah so genomics is lab that that is
pretty much where
um you know this is this is literally in
the lab
uh so since we're not going to be
physically in the lab uh so this is what
uh we call it the virtual lab
um so pretty much we're doing all the
experiments in the computer instead of
the lab
uh thank you leah for giving me the
opportunity to uh all right
so thank you sonya um so
i think that now we heard about the
program
the topics and i think it will give you
a view of what a bioinformatician really
does
and how they can apply different
bioinformatics tools to a variety of
different challenges
now to transition i want to pass this on
to dr mohit mizunder who will guide us
through
the schedule of the program and the
registration
thank you and hello everyone
let me know if you can see my screen yes
your screen is visible
is it visible yes sir it's visible
sorry maybe i'm not uh hearing you back
uh
thank you thank you so much
yeah hello everyone and thank you so
much
and uh dr professor sona
and nalika to help and all the bioclues
members
to help us uh guide through the entire
program and how it will be
what are the benefits what are the
applications whom this
is for so uh genomics in the virtual lab
and this is the second version of it so
we did genomics in the virtual lab
in 2020 and we have had like really
amazing results
working with many high school students
and also
undergraduate and postgraduate students
from india joined
and many other places who would want to
get
a understanding of how genomics is
applied
in different areas of bioinformatics
and different areas of life science and
biological research
so uh one thing that i think
we have discussed quite a bit is uh the
application of
genomic research in um
in biomedical research in translational
biomedical research
but with our collaborators and the
phases of this program which i'll be
going through right now
with you all of you uh we will learn
that that you will learn that that
genomics can be applied to a various
uh different areas like agriculture and
many of you might have
uh have an bend towards working on
something like that
so we'll be able to help you that during
the project phase as well
so now talking about the program so it
has
the the entire program is divided into
uh thinking of a concept of how genomics
can be
applied in basic research and as well as
how genomics can be applied to
understand
healthcare research and healthcare
system and improve the healthcare system
so that from developing a hypothesis to
be able to work on translational
research
so those are some of the objectives of
this program
so introducing uh the program from the
for the
from the first week we will have the
introduction to bioinformatics session
so that will be the first session and as
if you already have
said that this session will be freely
available
to uh those who are interested in
joining the entire program
so in this session we will start with uh
the basic
of bioinformatics understand how
bioinformatics started
understands its application and we'll go
through a course work
of introduction to bioinformatics which
is available on the platform
that you will have access to so uh
followed by that the second day we will
be learning about protein structure and
function this will be
again uh with the help of uh dr sona
here
uh professor sona here she will be uh
she'll be leading this session and
letting us learn about how protein
structure and functions
are related and then we will learn about
sequence analysis
and sequence alignment and phylogenetic
analysis and how these
evolutionary and analysis helps in
evolutionary and
uh and understanding of evolutionary
distances
and then the research that enables us to
learn about the origin
and or understand all those questions
that are relevant to
today's biomedical problems so next
session we will have we will have
about mutations and 3d structures and by
this time we will learn about how we can
apply some of these techniques on
different data sets
so we we started to work on data sets
and then we have a review and activity
session
and this will be a guest session where
we'll have games and
we'll have different kind of activities
that will be associated with the
you know with aspects of genomics and uh
the guest lecture will involve
uh someone which is again a surprise and
which will
be which we will be announcing very soon
uh will give you an insight of how
genomics can apply
is being applied and is helping a lot of
people
uh with many disabilities and problems
so after the completion of the first
week and
uh that will be uh by 25th uh
25th june we'll be finishing the last
session and during the weekend
we'll have weekend activities and during
this time
before the end of the week we will be
providing you with the details of
the assignments and how you can
complete the assignment and what all
other elements are there
that you need to complete and we will be
sharing those details with you the data
sets
and then we will have a review session
starting next week where we will be
reviewing the video presentations
and we already have a lot of examples uh
of people completing these
weekend activities and i would request
sonalika if you can paste some of the
links
of the participants who completed
the program last time and completed the
weekend activity video
videos so that so the students here can
understand that how it could be
so the second week is going to be more
about research so you understand about
the structure and function
how genomics is applied and with the
help of professor sona
we will have such a amazing interactive
sessions that
i can assure and guarantee you that that
because
uh last time it we have had an amazing
experience going through this entire
journey
learning from her learning from
different tools that she's been part of
uh while developing so after that we
will be transitioning into the second
week
where we will learn about the
application of genomics
in virology and also we will understand
from many case studies
and how you can apply this understanding
of genomics
by first doing literature review so we
will start from the
basic of research and we have a very
structured programs
that are leading to uh high value
research
so we have several examples of those and
many of our
interns who have joined are working on
research projects using the same process
so we start from literature review we
will go through different repositories
that you will learn that
learn and you will find interesting
articles and that would be really
an amazing experience for those who are
interested in doing something new
a new research so finding out what has
been done
and how people have achieved those will
be some of the objectives of this
session
and how you can design a process and
design a project
using that information with the help of
experts
so this will be the first session after
the review
of the first week's activity so review
process and feedback process
is a very important and a very important
pillar in this
omics logic uh bioinformatics research
trainings and especially genomics in the
lab
we have sessions or very intensive
sessions like because we have
sessions every day so we'll be expecting
you to be
endorsed with all the experts and make
the most of this opportunity
so next session after learning about and
identifying
the research question we will be
learning about
how you can you know identify viral
species
and strains and do comparative analysis
of violent genomes
understand the viral diversity and then
understand
how this is related how the mutations
are related to the disease
how it is related to the disease
pathology what are the phenotypic to
genotypic changes so how machine
learning and how
sorry how next generation sequencing
is playing a key role in genomics for
biology
so that would be the second session of
the second week
after that we will learn about more
about the diversity of microbial
communities
so here we will learn about bacterial
genomes and then
we will learn about 16 srnas and we'll
learn about
uh how metagenomics can can be applied
to study uh directly samples that you
can culture
in the lab so that is such a big
advantage that we have with
with the metagenomics technology and you
will be learning about how metagenomics
technology can be applied
to answer many of those important
questions in this
difficult pandemic time where there is
so much of
data is being generated related to kobe
19.
so after that i mean once you have
applied and learned about
how genomics metagenomics plays a role
in identifying understanding in the
respect of
in the respect of finding these problems
that you're working on on the aspect of
project uh project and all so in this
session we will learn about the basic
principles between
behind antiviral and active
antibacterial drug
and the approaches for vaccine design so
it's a very important topic
and this can be done like once you have
the holistic
understanding and overview of all of the
topics that we covered
we come to this stage uh where we are
talking about antibodies and antiviral
drugs
so the earlier understanding is equally
important for you to come to this stage
and to make the most and understand the
translational value
of uh genomics
so the next session after that uh on uh
second july uh will be about hands-on
session
uh analysis of genomics from ncbi virus
so we will be going to ncbi virus
we will be downloading the genomes and
we'll be using the t bind for server
to analyze those genomes so we also have
some of the
project examples that we have already
prepared for you for this program
that you will be utilizing and learning
from so those examples will also be
available
on the learn or mix logic platform that
you have that you will have access
to and subscription to you throughout
this program
so after the completion of second week
we will be working on the weekend
to develop these projects ideas into
presentations
so this is a first step to work towards
a
program so one of the practical outcome
of outcomes of this program
is that you get a feedback
from a renowned expert in the field of
genomics in the field of disease
research in the field of
all the other genomic application so we
here we have uh renowned scientists
from all around india all around uh from
many
uh renowned universities in the us so
you will have an expert
panel to discuss uh about those project
feed project proposals that you will
come up with so
one of the objectives as i was telling
you is to develop an
independent research project that could
be reviewed in this entire process
so after the completion of the two
scheduled uh
you know weeks so the first phase is the
first week
by dr sona the second phase uh by
omixlogic team
on all of this that you have seen and
the fourth and
third and the fourth week will be more
about
research project so we will be working
with experts
and we will have group sessions and
one-on-one sessions
to develop a research project and that
requires a few steps
so i'll just quickly describe you those
steps so the first step
to a research project is to find a
problem
right first you have to find a problem
uh and then
you have to find very then you have to
be very specific
and be focused that the that the problem
that you're interested in
so that uh that would be from you
you will be have you will have that
opportunity to come up with your own
research project
and also will have opportunity to work
on already prepared projects that are
available
so after doing that we will be doing the
literature review as i've already
told you and then we will do exploratory
analysis
where we will look into different data
sets and find those
insights from that data set so entire
process
of uh of uh working
from uh week to week will uh
help us develop some of those research
projects and i think uh i'll also
request an alikar to maybe share
some of those completed research
projects with you here as well
so this is about the program and how we
are going to uh
going to go through this journey one
month journey research journey
and now i would like to maybe take you
to the registration process
and show you how you can register for
the program
so maybe i'll find the link in the chat
so sonalika if you can paste the
registration okay it's here
that's the blog post
so once you have a login you will find
yourself
uh like this like a name and then
in this you'll have a profile so once
you log in you'll see like this
but if you have not login then
then i recommend you to create a free
login on the learn platform on the
omixlogic and start exploring
many of the opportunities that we bring
you here
so genomics in the virtual lab you can
find it here
and then
[Music]
then you go in and then you start your
application so this is a free workshop
and
if you want us to if you want us to send
you more
emails and details about the program
then you can request for more
information and submit your details
and as you have joined this program i
believe many of you have already
registered
so you have done your registration part
but now you have to finish your
registration by completing
uh and submitting the uh
registration fees so i'll go to the
registration fees and i'll describe you
different
levels of levels that we have
for you to join and explore so beginners
level
as i showed you all of those uh things
that we will do
has all the features uh to complete this
course and get a certificate
and then we have the intermediate level
if you think that you need
additional sessions with one of us one
of the mentors
then you can opt for the intermediate
level so that will give you an option to
have
a couple of sessions with the mentor to
guide you
and give you an hands-on experience by
doing screen sharing and helping you
through go through the resources and all
of that and the tutorials
so if you require that level of uh that
level of support you can opt for
intermediate
and the third option is advanced advance
is for an
additional work to work additionally on
your project so if you are working on a
project
and if you already have a proposal ready
and you're working maybe with a lab
or you're working with some university
so you can opt for an advanced license
as well so once you select a license and
i'll go here
then you have an option where you can
fill up about the details uh
your card details and how you are going
to submit the fee and at the same time
you can also
add promotional codes so these
promotional codes are given up as
scholarships so we have given a lot of
scholarships
to our previous participants before who
would want to join this program and
could not afford the full
price of this uh there's so much logic
program
so you can apply for scholarship and
i'll request an alika again i'm so sorry
that i'll i have to request you again
and again but
uh please if you can share the
scholarship form as well
that would be great so uh yeah as i was
telling you that uh with
scholarships you can again do this and
if you're a bio clues
member then please reach out to bioclues
uh
bioclues members who are
available here and maybe uh any any of
you can share the email address to reach
out to and then
you will get a promotional code from
bioclues and then you can apply that bio
queues promotion code and get
uh get a scholarship from bioclues
as well so i welcome you all to
complete this and join us for this
one month hands-on mentor guided
research training program
and if you have any questions and any
issues
feel free to reach out to us and we'll
be happy to
help you out with this so my email
address is movie.greatpine.bio
and i i think we'll share other email
addresses as well
so thank you i think i'll now look at
the questions and i'll pass it on to
sonalika for any other
questions that uh you may have
thank you so much dr mohit here in the
chat i have also shared the blog
post link with you all so that you can
go through what all would be covered all
the session details are mentioned there
as well
and also there are few of the sample
projects by some of our students from
the
previous genomics in the virtual lab
program and also i'll share the links of
those projects
so that you can go watch them and get
the insights of how it is done
what the outcomes are and how things
would work actually
and also i'll share this scholarship
form so the process
is once you fill out the scholarship
form you have to submit your cv and also
the references from your institution we
would be reviewing them
and then we would get back to you on
that and as sir has already mentioned
the registration form i'm also sharing
the link with you those who are
interested
please register so once we get your
information we would
uh get back to you soon on that and if
you have any doubts uh please mail us at
mohit pine dot bio or marketing other a
pine dot bio
and before we end this session i would
welcome you all to follow us on linkedin
as well
following us there and being a part of
the group would help you know about
all our upcoming programs and trainings
and also know about whatever courses we
update
it was nice to meet you all here thanks
for being a part of the webinar
if you have any doubts you you can reach
out to us and thank you so much
by your close team thank you so much dr
sona vasudevan for coming and sharing
such mind bog like mind boggling things
and
it was a pleasure to have you here thank
you so much bye bye through steam and
thank you everyone for being here
now we'll meet in our next uh session
let's all meet there and discuss more
about the program and
begin with the program on 21st and uh
even now i am myself very very much
excited to be a part of the program
uh thank you so much we'll see
we'll see you all soon in the sessions
then bye bye take care
you